hi guys I'm Tom Mo I'm one of the
founders of cartoon Saloon and it's
great to meet you in person can I ask
you all about what are you most proud
of you guys what you what proud of um
I'm very proud of that there was a
little idea that popped into my head 11
years ago and it brought me to so many
talented people and uh together we we
formed
this film and now it's it's done it was
an awesome ride for everybody at some
point you're high at some point you're
down at some point you just wanted to
stop when you come to the university in
the morning and everybody else is is
there and giving their best and there's
a new puppet or new piece of music a new
set it's just amazing and it keeps you
going and going and going what the year
what you most proud of in s tears I
think with this film we had a song story
to tell and what of the thing that is
really cool is that when we go to
festival or when we talk about the film
with anyone they are like telling us
that they didn't know about and they
tried their best to see what it was to
search on Google and find out what
happened great so yeah me too actually
it was informative for me about that but
it is and I have one memory from a
festival when we we show the film and at
the end there is a guy which wasant and
um he came to us and just told us thank
you it was really really poor because
which was really great H for us I don't
know it felt special yeah that sounds
amazing and what are you most proud of L
um what am I most proud of uh I my
film's very bizarre that it is kind of
its own behind the scenes so I think I'm
proud of like that I'll be able to look
back on it like in in like five see what
you did at your lockdown time yeah I
think that's nice and any reactions to
your movie that surprised you did
anybody say something that you didn't
expect them to say I'm I'm just
surprised that it's that it's that it
worked as a film
[Laughter]
that so what are you most proud of in
your in your movie I think this is my
first personal film yeah um where it's
not just my own story but it's also
using my
voice and yeah the story itself is about
learning how to trust your own mind and
trust your own voice even which just
huge for everyone get every stage in
like yeah yeah that's a beautiful thing
to put into the
world my advice is keep moving keep
moving and don't look back too much and
think too much cuz you'll get paralyzed
you know we started our studio when we
were in college too and um I'd been a
member of young Irish filmmakers in
kileny and they gave us space to get our
first movie started and by the time we
got it made it was like 10 years and
then yeah there's a scary moment cuz
you're like oh like can I do it again
like you know it's that so my advice is
always to get started on the next one as
soon as possible don't let that pressure
build up for too long like if you're
already start it's like chain smoking
you know have to like the next one up to
put in a previous one you when you made
like a n how did you think about the
characters when you first started
designing the characters how did you go
about it did you make them or did you
draw um well I I had come up with the
idea um in 2011 and I saw a t-shirt with
a deep SE diver and um and an astronaut
on a on a seesaw then years later at
University I met Sebastian and um I had
some ideas for the characters and he put
it into these beautiful designs what
made you choose stop motion for this
movie rather than any other St but for
me um for example it was a magical
moment when you animate this uh in the
set and hit the play button and then you
see this this is
life for the S tear you seem to have a
slightly stop motion feel to your
character design how how did you
approach the character design with the
beginning we knew that we had a story
and a subject that was a little bit
tough so we wanted to search in this St
motion aspect is more easy like to watch
I imagine and we Rel liked it so we were
trying to get influences from the of
course like for example my life I'm
zucchini oh yeah my life is zucchini was
great yeah did you design the characters
by actually modeling in 3D or did you
draw or did you straight to computer we
went straight in TR we had to find some
solutions to have a big crowd with few
amounts of assets so we tried to go with
the style of the characters that could
swap the assets like the nose the
mustache the the eyes and
everything question everything young man
the world is not quite what it seems
tell me a little bit about the design
process of the ostrich yeah so for me
like some for some reason at the start
like I I'm thinking about design but I'm
also thinking about how big they're
going to be in the real world so
for this film I like I made them smaller
than than I previously did like about
about this big and then like made the
head bigger and I guess that's important
is it like to decide the size cuz it's
going to dictate the detail of the the
detail and then the scale of the
textures and materials that you're using
look differently at at different scales
that you're using so yeah it's a very
important thing it changes the whole
look depending on how big it I guess
your sitting room was a no go area where
everything was set up like oh yeah
somebody tou months yeah somebody
knocked something over or something yeah
and because there was two c there's one
camera shooting a monitor and then
another camera there's like this like
dead zone that you can't go anywhere
near like wow so wow so you shot it all
in your sitting room
yeah when I was really young like before
I started going to school I used to have
nightmares how about you live is your
your Technique different um do you
storyboard at all or it was honestly a
lot more fluid so I knew I wanted to
make this film about lucid dreaming I
had had like all these amazing
experiences during the pandemic about it
did you storyboard then or start to make
sketches or did you go straight to the
AI and say give me some ideas animatron
yeah that's what
C the way that the tech works best is
when you put your own images into it so
you're kind of able to imprint your own
style amazing isn't it it's fascinating
you seriously heartfelt congratulations
to y'all I think it's amazing excit to
see what y'all do
[Music]
next